نحى الكرد كل خلافاتهم جانبا وفي توافق
لافت للانتباه قرروا رفع العلم الكردي الى
جانب العلم العرق في كركوك رغم اعتراض
الجميع ثم تجاهلوا قرار مجلس النواب
العراقي الرافض لهذه الخطوه وقررت الكتله
الكرديه في مجلس المحافظه في غياب
المكونات الاخرى من عرب وتركمان التوجه
لمطالبه الحكومه المركزيه باجراء استفتاء
على ضم كركوك الى اقليم كردستان ما الذي
فجر هذه القضيه في هذا التوقيت بالذات وما
هي البدائل التي سيلجا اليها الاكراد كما
يقولون في حال رفض هذا الاستفتاء وما هي
خيارات الحكومه العراقيه ازاء تجاهل
الاكراد لموقفها ولقرارات مجلس النواب قبل
النقاش نتابع تقرير محمد
ابراهيم لم تكد تهدا العاصفه التي اثارها
قرار اكراد مجلس محافظه كركوك برفع علم
اقليم كردستان فوق المؤسسات الحكوميه حتى
تفجر خلاف جديد في المحافظه التي تصنف ضمن
المناطق المتنازع عليها في الدستور
العراقي مجلس محافظه كركوك وبحضور اعضائه
الاكراد فقط صوت على المضي في اجراء
استفتاء للانضمام الى اقليم
كردستان لم يكتفي المجلس بتلك الخطوه التي
غاب عنها المكونان الاساسيان في المدينه
العرب والتركمان بل رفض ايضا قرار
البرلمان العراقي الذي طالب قبل ايام
بانزال علم كردستان من على المباني
الحكوميه في كركوك سياسه الامر الواقع بدا
ان اكراد المحافظه ماضون قدما في فرضها
فاللجوء لكل الخيارات مفتوح كما يقول
اعضاء المجلس من الاكراد في حال رفضت
الحكومه العراقيه اجراء الاستفتاء خيارات
او اجراءات ربما من بينها تدويل القضيه او
ضرب عرض الحائط باي قرارات حكوميه مرتقبه
كركوك خامس مدن العراق من حيث عدد السكان
ازمه تعود للواجهه اذا في ظل وضعها
الاستثنائي فالمحافظة
وال تركمانيه واصبحت اليوم تحت سلطه
القوات الكرديه في وقت ما زال تنظيم
الدوله يسيطر فيه على اجزاء واسعه منها
القوى السياسيه الكرديه وخاصه قطبي جلال
طالباني ومسعود البارزاني وضعت خلافاتها
جانبا وتوصلت لتوافق منقطع النظير بشان ضم
المحافظه الغنيه بالنفط لاقليم كردستان
العراق الامر الذي تعتبره الحكومه
والبرلمان العراقيان غير دستوري وشقا
للصفوف العرب والتركمان يرفضون تلك
الاجراءات ايضا ويتمسكون بخصوصيه المحافظه
وعلاقتها بالحكومه المركزيه في بغداد فهل
يمكن للاعضاء الاكراد في مجلس محافظه
كركوك فرض امر واقع رغم تعارضه مع طبيعه
الاستفتاء في الدستور العراقي اجراء
الاستفتاء في المحافظه هو ثالث ثلاث خطوات
اقرها الدستور العراقي في مادته رقم
140 بشان مصير
تبدا بالتطبيع ثم الاحصاء وتنتهي
بالاستفتاء امام هذا الواقع تجد الحكومه
العراقيه نفسها في ظل خيارات صعبه وهي
تخوض معركه طاحنه ضد تنظيم الدوله في
الموصل وتواجه محاولات من اطراف داخليه
منافسه لانها كها عبر اثاره ازمات داخليه
قد تكون كركوك واحده منها لا شك ان ملف
كركوك في هذه المرحله الحساسه سيزيد اوضاع
العراق تعقيدا ويفتح الباب على فصل اخر من
الجدل الدستوري والسياسي يفاقم ازمات
متلاحقه يدفع ثمنها الاكبر الشعب العراقي
المنهك والذي اصبحت مكوناته في تباعد اكثر
فاكثر منذ الغزو
الامريكي ينضم الينا من اربيل المحلل
السياسي الدكتور عبد الحكيم خسرو ومن
بغداد عضو كتله ائتلاف دوله القانون عدنان
السراج دكتور خسرو ابدا منك الان اعضاء
الكتله الكرديه في مجلس محافظه كركوك
يقولون اذا رفض موضوع الاستفتاء فاللجوء
الى كل الخيارات امر مفتوح عن اي خيارات
يتحدثون ما هي هذه
الخيارات مساء الخير
طبعا قرار مجلس المحافظه اليوم هو قرار
باتجاه الحكومه الاتحاديه وطلب من الحكومه
الاتحاديه باجراء الاستفتاء او اكمال
ا الفصول الماده 140 من الدستور العراقي
والماده 58 من قانون اداره الدوله لمرحله
الانتقاليه يعني كل كل هذه اتصور هناك
مبالغه في هذا الامر لم يتم ضم كركوك الى
اقليم كردستان باي قرار ورفع علم اسحي
اسمحي دكتور حتى يعني نستفيد من الوقت ولا
نستغرق في معذره معذره افهم هذا ولكن
السؤال ما هي الخيار التي يتحدث عنها
الاكراد اذا رفض موضوع
الاستفتاء طبعا هي الخيارات هو اللجوء الى
الاستفتاء بصوره منفرده من قبل ابناء
كركوك او من قبل الطلب من اقليم كردستان
ومفوضي العليا في اقليم كردستان باعتبار
هناك مفوضيه وهذه المفوضيه لديها
الصلاحيات في اجراء الاستفتاء
في داخل اقليم كردستان وايضا في المناطق
الكردستان انيه خارج اقليم كردستان هذا ما
قره برلمان الاقليم وبالتالي هذه احد
الخيارات المهمه التي من الممكن اللجوء
اليها في المستقبل طبعا هذه بعد بعد
التوصل
الى يعني عدم التوافق مع الحكومه
الاتحاديه هنا هل هناك
14 وايضا بتنفيذ ما عليها من
التزامات لا طبعا لا توجد خيارات اخرى كل
الخيارات هي
باتجاه الافتاء اراده الناخبين واراده
طيب طعا
رش بانه لا يمكن الهيمنه على هذه المناطق
بدون اراده هذه المناطق سيد عدنان السراج
ما عواقب ان يلجا الاكراد لخطوه كهذه
الاستفتاء بشكل منفرد اذا ما رفض رفضت
الحكومه
مطلبهم بالتاكيد الحكومه سترفض مطلبهم ما
دام الاجراءات غير دستوريه وقانونيه اضافه
لذلك هناك التركمان والعرب وهناك خلافات
عن حجم الاكراد وتواجدهم داخل ال داخل
كركوك هذا واضح جدا ولكن من الذي سيحصل لو
تم الاستفتاء مثلا لو راحوا بشكل منفرد
وعمل الاستفتاء من الذي سيعترف بهذا
الانضمام اي قانون واي دستور واي دوله
تعترف بهذا الاتجاه بالتاكيد سيكون اجراء
غير قانوني وغير دستوري ولا يمكن ان ينفذ
على مستوى العراق لانه سيكون رفضا قاطعا
اولا الدوله الرف الرفض واضح الرفض واضح
من جميع الاطراف ولكن دعني اسالك ايضا ما
هي خيارات الحكومه خاصه الاكراد واضح انهم
لا يكترثون لرفض مجلس النواب او رفض
الحكومه او ما شابه
ذلك لا هم لحد الان لم يشاهدوا عقوبات
الدوله يعني لحد هذه الدقيقه الدوله تمسك
العصا من الوسط على امل ان يرجعوا الى
رشدهم وتبدا قضيه حكيمه اليوم رئس الوزراء
قال اتصل ب محافظ
ماذا عد اجراءات اولى ممكن الذهاب الى
المحكمه الاتحاديه وبعد الذهاب الى
المحكمه الاتحاديه والتاكيد واضح جدا ان
الاساليب والطرق التي سلكوها هي غير قانون
دستوريه ثانيا سيبدا عمليات اقاله مجلس
المحافظه بطلب من ثلثين اعضاء مجلس النواب
وايضا يستطيع رئيس الوزراء حسب الماده
السبعه من العش
باحاله الطلب الى مجلس النواب باقاله
المحافظ وهذا بالتاكيد سيحصل بالاغلبيه
بسيطه فلذلك اعتقد هذه الاجراءات العاديه
اما الاجراءات الاخرى فاعتقد هناك ضغوطات
سياسيه ستجري ضغوطات اقتصاديه ستجري هناك
امور اخرى ستجري باتجاه العوده الى المربع
الاول كما قيل يعني نحن متفقون مع الاقليم
بان تؤجل كل الخلافات الى معركتنا ما بعد
داعش وبالتالي يمكن التفاهم بامور اخرى في
هذه المناطق اما الاستباق بهذا الامر
وتصعيد الامور بهذه الطريقه لا اعتقد
القري ق قادر على فعل ذلك طيب دكتور خصرو
لماذا فجرت هذه القضيه الان في وقت يعني
اي السيد العبادي يتحدث عن ان الحكومه
مشغوله في المعركه مع تنظيم الدوله وما
الى ذلك هل هو استباق الاستحقاقات ما بعد
معركه الموصل ام ماذا لماذا فجرت القضيه
الان يعني بالنسبه للتوقيت وكيفيه التعامل
مع هذه المساله اتصور بان ا ما يدور الان
حول انهاء هذا الملف ملف ملف كركوك وملف
اداره كركوك والتعامل مع هذه القضيه كان
بسبب الخلافات الموجوده خلافات موجوده
داخل كركوك خلافات موجوده مع الحكومه
الاتحاديه تلكؤ الحكومه الاتحاديه لعده
سنوات من تنفيذ الماده 140 من اهمال
اللجنه او حتى توقف اللجنه ماده 140 من
الدستور العراقي عن العمل يعني يعني لماذا
لم يحدث هذا الامر يعني الخطوات التي
اتخذها الاكراد لماذا لم تحدث قبل سته
اشهر او ع اشهر او سنه ونصف او سنتين
لماذا تحدث
الان هذه طبعا هذه خطوه لابد ان تبدا يعني
سواء كان اليوم ولماذا لم يبدا خلال اشهر
لكن خطوه كان لابد من القيام بها وقد
بداوا بها يعني هذه هذه مساله ليس
بالمسالا ال جوهريه فيما يتعلق بكيفيه
التعامل مع قضيه كركوك في هذه المرحله لكن
الحكومه الت حاديه هي ملزمه بموجب الدستور
على تنفيذ الماده 140 وانهاء هذا الملف
ولكن عندما نجد ان هناك نوابا وكتل سياسيه
يتبجحون بانهم لم يقبلوا او اوقفوا عمل
الماده 140 من الدستور العراقي واوقف
عمليه الاستفتاء في كركوك ولم يتنازلوا
على كركوك ب طبعا
بصفه بصفه فرض الامر الواقع طبعا هذا كله
كان مؤشرات سلبيه ل النواب الكرد ول لكتل
الكردستان وحتى لاقليم كردستان لانه لا بد
من البدا بالعمل الحرب ضد داعش لا يوقف
العمل ال ماده 140 من الدستور العراقي
لماذا لم يتم وضع ميزانيه للماده 140 من
الدستور الع سيد عدنان السراج الاكراد كما
ترى وضعوا كل خلافاتهم جانبا وتطابق
موقفهم في هذه الجزئيه بشكل ملفت هل
الساسه العراقيون من المكونات الاخرى ايضا
سنح خلافاتهم جانبا ويت قون فيما يخص
كركوك والتطورات المتسارعه
فيها نعم بدا واضحا جدا اتفاق شيعي سني
عربي على هذا الاتجاه وبالعكس وحد السنه
والشيعه باتجاه المطالب العربيه وهذا لا
ينفع الكرد الكرد مختلفون اليوم بيان
التغيير يشير الى تخوف من هذه الاجراءات
ويرى ان برلمان الاقليم الذي عطل هو
المسؤول عن كل هذه الاجراءات وهم يتخوفون
من هذه الاجراءات كذلك هناك رائحه البترول
والخلافات بين الاتحاد وبين جماعه الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني انا اعتقد اليوم
هذا الاستباق سالت زميلي لسباق اعتقد هم
قراوا ان الجيش العراقي والحج الشعبي اصبح
قوه هم يتخوفون دائما من قوه الجيش
العراقي واعتقد اليوم هم يريدون طرح
الامور حتى على خلاف الواقع الداخلي
والاقليمي تجد ان الاقليم اليوم ايران
تركيا امريكا العالم حتى الامم المتحده لا
ترغب بمثل هكذا اجراد بل صرح تصريحات
واضحه بانهم ضد هذه الاجراءات فكيف يمكن
ان تمرر مثل هكذا استفتاء على حساب الدوله
اذا هو ضغط على حكومه بغداد في وضع بغداد
تشن حرب على داعش وفي النهايه هي تصل الى
النتيجه والدليل على ذلك ان السيد مسعود
البرزاني اشار عفوا بس هذه الجزئيه اشار
في قبل حوالي يوم الى ان معركه الموصل هذا
تصريح جديد سيكون هناك يعني اجراءات اخرى
ستتخذ بعد تحرير الموصل والموصل لا يمكن
تحديد اطارها بالطريقه التي تطرحها بغداد
فاذا هناك عوده مراجعه لمسائل تتعلق
بالمناطق دكتور خسر السيد عدنان السراج
ذكر الحشد الشعبي والحشد الشعبي دائما
يعني كرر مرارا وتكرارا انه ضد التوجه
الذي يعني يخطو نحوه الاكراد هل الاكراد
مستعدون لاحتمال الاصطدام ربما عسكريا
بالحشد
الشعبي
يعني بصوره عامه لا يمكن الحديث عن مساله
الاصطدام بين الحجز الشعبي
والقوات البيشمركه في هذه المرحله وهذه
خطووه غير متعقده اصور
بانه جرب هذا الامر قبلهم عبد الكريم قاسم
وعبد الرحمن عارف وعبد السلام عارف و صدام
حسين والبكر وبالتالي وصل العراق ما وصل
اليه طبعا تنازلوا تنازلوا عن شط العرب في
في سبيل الابقاء على كركوك تنازلوا عن
حدودهم مع الكويت في سبيل تنازل عن يعني
البقاء على الكركوك طبعا هذه خطوات يعلمون
جيدا التاريخ ويجب ان يتذكروا التاريخ بان
ما سبب الويلات هو عدم حل القضيه الكرديه
لابد من وجود حل عادل للقضيه الكرديه حتى
لا يصلوا الى ما وصلوا اليه في المراحل
السابقه اذا ارادوا الاستمرار في هذه هذا
منوال اتصور بان هذا سوف يؤدي ولكن لا
اتصور بان هناك حرب او قتال هناك ربما
تخفيف من هذا التصعيد الموجود بين بغداد
واربيل شكرا لك من اربيل المحلل السياسي
ددكتور عبد الحكيم خسرو ومن بغداد كان
معنا عضو كتله ائتلاف دوله القانون عدنان
السرات شكرا جزيلا
لكما جوليو ريجيني هو اسم الباحث الايطالي
الذي عثر عليه ميتا قبل اكثر من عام في
القاهره وهو كذلك عنوان لازمه بين ايطاليا
ومصر تطفو حينا وتختفي حينا اخر الجديد في
هذا الملف معز شش